hey guys Ryan right here I'm gonna be
watching the third trailer for
interstellar movie about going through a
wormhole space travel and Matthew
McConaughey being a dramatic version of
Matthew McConaughey I am interested in
watching this I really just want to go
for the IMAX experience any movie that
shot with IMAX cameras I've practically
seen them all like The Dark Knight Dark
Knight Rises Mission Impossible Ghost
Protocol Catching Fire so yeah I love
good IMAX experience and I think out of
all the directors the man who started it
is the one who can still do it best and
that is Christopher [ __ ] Nolan so I
just want to see more footage of this
I'm hoping this is the last trailer
because the best thing about Nolan
movies is the more that's left to
mystery the better there's some intense
perilous action
what are you gonna do give it such a
socially responsible can't was just like
oh I see something that a damper okay
let's back up the rest of us
that's caring honest baseball's a
treasure there's been towns to leave for
a while now
your daughter's generation will be the
last survive on that build best pilot we
ever had
get out there the safety works play
racing abide our solar system to our
galaxy here we go
kind of [ __ ] easy
get down fast don't actually want to get
there one piece
we have a mission our mission does not
work with the people on earth are dead
by the time we pull it off
this farther than any human in history
or not Fargo
the way whoa
yes you are yes you are you might have
to decide to see your children again the
human race
but we always have I really don't know
about you guys but I think that's the
best trailer this movie's released so
far what I really gathered from this
were the performances it's like
especially with the raining they were
like there's only some action in it and
I was thinking this probably gonna be a
long picture and the way it's moving it
really seems to be an emotional journey
I like those science fiction films a lot
of them are like indie flix where it's a
science fiction film but it's sort of
grounded in realism so the sci-fi is not
too out there
this film looks like it's like that but
with a much bigger budget I don't know
if it's going to go all crazy sci-fi on
us like towards the end of the movie or
what not as far as this goes it looks
like the main focus is really the
characters the story of survival the
struggle like all those things is what
it seems like this movie is really about
while taking place during this
fictitious time like the performances
especially from Matthew McConaughey look
like it's gonna be [ __ ] solid like I
feel like this movie won't need a bunch
of action this movie won't need a bunch
of danger like the danger we felt
through all because of the circumstances
we won't need a bunch of crazy visual
effects you know intense action scenes
because we'll be so invested in the
characters that by the time those
sequences come they'll be even more
intense as opposed to them putting
several intense scenes if that makes
sense
it just seems perfectly casting from
like the two lines we heard Anne
Hathaway say it's like you know what I
think I might not get annoyed by her in
this film there's something about Anne
Hathaway where I'm always prepared to
get annoyed by her and then I watched
the film and then I'm like no I actually
really enjoyed that Hathaway I don't
know like Anne Hathaway it looks like
she's gonna do a great job in this and I
just love the music in the trailer -
like those Nolan films man such an ass
for not knowing the composer's name off
the top of my heart is it Hans Zimmer I
think it's Hans immer he just creates
the best music for these films I hope
it's this guy again I mean if not it
still sounds great so yeah man it's just
going to have like a nolan story at its
best where it seems like it's really
about the characters in the story above
all else really thank you guys a lot for
letting me that trailer was
that was [ __ ] awesome if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects where we have so many
things on here that if you know you
don't like one thing you might like the
other thing and if you only like one
thing just wait for that one thing to be
uploaded rosh kupo I just started
watching your channel and noticed you
and the other rejects enjoy video game
trailers also I'm going to give a shout
out to Sally's hotness yes her hotness
is so awesome it deserves its own
comment shout out Irish kupo no one ever
gives shoutouts to any of the rejects
like that so I wanted to say thank you
this is what you call earning a
shout-out as opposed to asking for one
which is also a way of earning a
shout-out the qualifications are quite
simple harue show Kubo Hruska bow
haurache coop oh [ __ ]
what was your name I could choose to
shout-out someone right now I choose you
because you're very kind
and I hit ctrl search and I typed in
shout-out and yours was the first one
that came up I did not realize you were
not asking for a burly kiddin can I get
a shout-out burly kitten let's face it
that's what I call my penis cuz you know
I'd like to have the bush the bush I
think is really necessary you need a lot
of the bush you know like the Harrier
and the better is what I say same thing
on a vagina
the Harrier the better I like to I like
to get the hair caught in the back of my
throat after going down on a girl that's
kind of a John ISM into I like my penis
looked that way and so you know I call
it the burly kitten cuz it's always on
the prowl and it likes to claim his
territory
it usually likes to rest but if it wants
to spend time with you it will I think I
made it work Cameron Adams hey can I get
a shout out love your channel
Cameron Adams you love this channel what
other channels do you love and do I
approve of the other channels you love
here's who I absolutely hate Jeremy
Jones
stuckman schmoes no like these guys are
nothing and gator martin you can go [ __ ]
yourself gator martin like people are
like always saying my channel is so much
along the lines of those guys's channels
not true not true at all just because
they do movie reviews and decade or
Martin does trailer reactions does not
make my channel like theirs okay Cameron
Adams so quit watching their [ __ ]
channels and only watch mine but on a
serious note those are the only
youtubers I actually watch and I lie to
the rest of the rejects and tell them i
watch their channels as well that
includes my girlfriend